the migrant caravan reaches the border
and all hell breaks loose Twitter moves
to ban science and the Russians get
aggressive with the Ukrainians I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
well I hope you have the wonderful they
had a wonderful Thanksgiving weekend and
they came back all refreshed we had a
great Thanksgiving at my house in my
house we did all of the typical
Thanksgiving things we had the great
Thanksgiving food we spent a lot of time
with family and half the family nearly
died of dysentery that's a thing that
pretty much actually happened we'll get
to all of the news in just one second
but first let's talk about we're now
past Thanksgiving right so we can talk
about Christmas we can talk about buying
holiday gets for people and that means
it's time to tell you the gifts you need
to get for the guys in your life mine
crates the man crates know what guys
like they have hundreds of unique
quality gifts that he is guaranteed to
love they've got the exotic meats crate
the whiskey appreciation crate that has
a personalized de cáncer and
personalized glasses the perfect vessels
for his favorite scotch or bourbon you
know on Twitter I said that no real man
likes whiskey everybody really likes
strawberry daiquiris and then I received
the man crate of whiskey appreciation
and I have to admit it's rare that I had
been a mistake
but I will say the man crate of whiskey
appreciation is pretty fantastic also
they've got the grillmaster crate a
knife making court they got all sorts of
great gifts and here's the best thing
about the man crates you get to find out
whether he is indeed a man because they
give you this crate it's like a wooden
crate with an actual crowbar and then
you have to pry open the man crate in
front of everyone see I didn't want to
humiliate myself so instead I just let
my children try to do it for like half
an hour and then when I did it it took
me 29 minutes then I look like a real
man listeners of this show buy one gift
in you'll get the second gift for 25%
off when you go to mine crates calm
slash been the offer is only for the
holidays by one gift get the second 25%
off at Mon crate stuff come / Ben that
is indeed Mon crates dot-com / Ben for
that special deal I love that advertiser
okay so let's talk about the news cuz a
lot of stuff happened over the weekend
cuz people just couldn't leave things
alone could you you just couldn't leave
it alone couldn't just go enjoy
Disneyland
you couldn't just enjoy the turkey
instead we had to have a bunch of news
so here is the latest over the weekend
hundreds of immigrants tried to storm
the border so we were told as you recall
that immigrants would not in fact try to
storm the border in this migrant caravan
I was one of the people saying that this
was a little overestimated wasn't gonna
be thousands of people trying to storm
the border in fact it was not
thousands of people was a couple of
hundred people I think one person
actually made it across the border and
then was immediately chased back across
the border but tear gas was fired at
these crowds because some of these
people were throwing rocks at Border
Patrol agents and here is what it
sounded like when hundreds of people
tried to storm the border between
Tijuana and the United States you can
see these folks breaking through a fence
running across no-man's land toward the
next fence and Border Patrol showed up
and they're flying what I do love about
this is that you can see that some of
them are flying the flag of Honduras and
Alexandra Acacio Cortez the new
congresswoman from New York and all of
her wisdom she said well this is just
like refugees like when the Jews were
trying to flee Nazi Germany
well when the Jews were fleeing Nazi
Germany they didn't arrive at Staten
Island at Liberty Island with the Nazi
flag on them right if you're actually
fleeing a place because of political
asylum needs you typically don't fly the
flag of the place from which you are
running also the vast majority these
people are not coming because of
political violence the vast majority of
these people are coming for economic
necessity which is a fine reason to try
and enter another country but you have
to do so legally you don't get to try to
break through the fence and that was not
just that video there's also video of
people who are pushing and trying to
push through the fence while shouting
yes we can hear they weren't want to be
border at one of the border patrol
stations at one of the big walls and
actually tried to force open the fence
[Music]
so you can see people they're standing
right outside the fence and some people
shouting si se puede and then it got
even worse there were some folks who
were actually physically throwing rocks
at members of Border Patrol which was
just delightful in this video if you
can't see it I will describe it for you
you can see folks who are actually
picking up rocks throwing them Border
Patrol agents and then there's the
famous picture that is now on the front
page of every newspaper of border patrol
having fired some teargas near the crowd
nobody apparently really got hurt but
here is some of the video what it sounds
like so you can see here's a guy picking
up stones turning around and trying to
throw it at Border Patrol you can see
them trying to fling the stones over the
fence at Border Patrol now once you do
that Border Patrol agents have every
right to defend themselves as they see
the need are these people we want to be
citizens of the United States are these
people we want to enter the United
States the answer of course is no if you
are throwing rocks at the members of our
Border Patrol well presumably attempting
to enter the country illegally we do not
want you here in the United States now
what's really funny is to watch a bunch
of folks on the Left downplay all this
stuff well though it didn't happen or if
it did happen it's not really a big deal
let's not make a big day at the same
time say it is so evil and so terrible
the tear gas was deployed against all of
these refugees these poor huddled masses
yearning to be free brian Stelter the
news guy over at CNN right his job is to
monitor media bias but he is a good
example of it himself brian Stelter
tweeted out I'm watching the coverage
the southern border is 1954 miles long
it's not being overwhelmed that is
legitimately one of the dummer points
I've ever heard about any sort of
attempt to breach a border it turns out
that the border between France and
Germany was several hundred miles long
and when the Germans moved through
Belgium in nineteen in 1939 and I in
that that was actually not and well they
let's see when they move through Belgium
yeah 1939 when they when they actually
moved in 1940 when they moved through
Belgium in 1940 it turns out that that
was a breach of the border that did not
require you to breach the entire border
at once all you have to do is breach one
point in the border and that would
amount to a border breach right then
it's and if people just rush through
that then that would be over well now
was the border overwhelmed
we had people there it was stopped still
this is evidence and if he didn't have
people there you didn't have a while you
can have some sort of physical
obstruction it would not be stopped
okay similans sanders another
commentator on CNN she said reminder
these are asylum seekers the United
States government is attacking asylum
seekers and this is after Chris Sherman
of The Associated Press tweeted u.s.
border patrol has just launched tear gas
in New Mexico breeze carrying at
hundreds of yards parents running away
with choking toddlers hashtag my grand
caravan okay so here is the question why
were the parents they are with the
choking toddlers near a place where
people were attempting to breach the
border wall we have border patrol
stations if people want to apply for
asylum all they have to do is walk up to
the Border Patrol station and ask for
asylum papers instead people are trying
to breach that border throwing rocks at
folks and then when teargas was fired
back then all of a sudden it's how dare
we do any of this so it turns out that
this is actually nothing new President
Obama in 2013 had a very similar
situation okay back in 2013 there are a
bunch of people who tried to break
through and during the Obama years it
turns out that tear gas was fired as
well the use of tear gas was used
several years back no one cared then
okay and it turns out that the caravan
confirms what President Trump has been
saying for a long time which is that the
aiding and abetting of this migrant
caravan to get them to the boards that
they could use violence against Border
Patrol agents and try break through the
border is a problem now did that require
15,000 troops down at the southern
border
no is it a massive crisis where
thousands of people are breaking through
the border and they're going to invade
the country no is it a problem yes of
course it's a problem this is not
stopping folks on the left from trying
to turn this into a human rights issue
Brian Schatz who is the senator from
Nevada he said who gave the order is
what he tweeted out as though this is
like he's now Tom Cruise and a few good
men and suddenly you're gonna see
President Trump going you want me on
that wall you need me on that wall
so he's the senator from Hawaii sorry
and he is an idiot who gave the order
well the order to defend yourself from
people throwing rocks at you without
killing people I mean probably like the
normal rules of engagement that apply in
any sort of conflict situation probably
that again I do find it ironic and weird
that so many folks on the Left are very
very upset at the deployment of like a
tear
gas canister at the border when people
are throwing rocks at our troops they
didn't care when Obama did it
I mean how they didn't care when Obama
was literally droning American citizens
who he said were terrorists I don't mind
throwing American citizens
maybe maybe who are terrorists maybe
although I think that's that's legally
dicey but it is amazing to watch all
these people suddenly rediscover their
feelings about civil liberties for
people attacking American troops when
it's a Republican who's president again
now what's hilarious about all of this
is that there are some Democrats who are
beginning to realize that maybe this
isn't the best election pitch maybe the
best election pitch for 2020 isn't we
don't care about the border to let
everybody through one of those people is
believe it or not Hillary Clinton so
over the weekend Hillary Clinton
admitted that Europe has badly
mishandled the migration crisis from the
Middle East here is what she had to say
about Europe's dealing with its own
borders and the migrant crisis that has
swamped Western Europe she said quote I
think Europe needs to get a handle on
migration because that is what lit the
flame I admire the very generous and
compassionate approaches that were taken
by leaders like Engel a Merkel of
Germany but I think it is fair to say
Europe has done its part and must send a
very clear message we are not going to
be able to continue providing refuge and
support because if we don't deal with
the migration issue it will continue to
roil the body politic and kind of
interesting where I mean that's exactly
what President Trump has been saying now
Democrats are starting to say that as
well John Kerry last week said something
very similar about the migrant crisis in
Europe and yet the Democratic Party in
the United States is embracing the
full-scale dovish position on
immigration that Hillary and Kerry won't
embrace with regard to Europe so why is
it okay for us to talk about the migrant
crisis in Europe but not to talk about
the migrant crisis with regard to Mexico
the answer of course is because
President Trump is not responsible for
immigration policy and Europeans
responsible for immigration policy in
the United States and that means that
they have to yell at President Trump no
matter what still members of the left
continue to push and promote the most
left-leaning version of what immigration
policy should be including of course the
op-ed page over at the New York Times
there's a piece by woman in just a
crispin over at the New York Times
called marrying him was political
sponsoring his visa is for love a
romantic pragmatic green card wedding
day here's what she says again this is
the New York Times promoting immigration
fraud basically says we were sitting in
a dive bar in Kansas
Missouri with two whiskey sodas and the
men I had met only ten days before I
said he had an important question to ask
me the last important question was what
is your relationship to potato chips
which he'd asked while gesturing to the
many bags of various flavors piled in my
pantry so it wasn't as if I was
expecting anything electric to come out
of his mouth I looked at him and he said
with the steady gaze would you marry me
I felt the strangest thing not joy not
shock not fear I felt calm calm is
everyone who knows me as aware is a rare
feeling for me but first I had to make
sure he wasn't making fun of me is that
a hypothetical or a practical question
both he said then yes we ordered another
round set a date for our courthouse
wedding four days later and immediately
began text our friends what why are you
sure I ignored them drunk on whiskey and
other stuff we stumbled out of the bar
this is obviously a recipe for excellent
decision-making as I stood on the curb
to hail a cab he ran to the drugstore
next door just need to get something he
came back his arms full of potato chips
bags of every flavor they had on the
shelves but marriage is not about love
it is about politics all of my adult
life I have argued for the abolition of
marriage because marriage is a series of
rights unfairly distributed to men and
women who have found love or have
deluded themselves into thinking they
have found love if romantic love is its
own reward as every Hollywood film a
novel in the woman's fiction section the
bookstore would have us believe
then why pile on tax breaks house a
hospital visitation health insurance
immigration assistance and all the rest
of it having a successful love life
should not have a determination on
whether you live or die
okay so this gets even more idiotic but
the bottom line is that this woman
basically married the guy in order so
that he could get immigration he said
holding my partner's hand at the
immigration lawyer's office I wanted so
much to give this to him a stabilized
future the ability to live and work
where he wanted a larger canvas for his
ambitions yet something in me started to
draw back at that moment a whirlwind
adventure of love and romance started to
look like a strategic seduction he might
fear that I might be mercenary I kept
thinking of that line spoken by Morris
Townsend in the movie the heiress based
on Henry James's Washington Square okay
and then this entire article just goes
on to describe how this woman basically
married the guy so that he would be able
to get in immigration a green card
basically she says marrying him was a
political act sponsoring him for a visa
is a devotional Act we were amassing a
file to prove that the relationship is
real and not a transaction the American
government gives you a list of things
that we'll be looking for to provide the
legitimacy of your love
she said the file where
both of us pictures we take of each
other are both for us and for the
government when I say what's your
niece's name again I'm asking it to set
it in my brain for the eventual quiz not
out of curiosity just delightful just
delightful so the New York Times
promoting essentially immigration fraud
at the same time that people are
storming the borders that's that's just
wonderful we'll get to more of the Left
failures on immigration and why
President Trump has an actual opening
here in just a second first let's talk
about how you need to mail a bunch of
stuff okay we are coming up on the
holiday season that means you're gonna
be mailing a lot of stuff do you really
want to slap all that stuff down in the
post office post office is great do you
really want to schlep it there or would
it be easier for you if you could just
get the exact postage print it out stick
it on package and then wait for the post
office to pick it up from your house or
from your office the answer of course is
the latter and that's why you need
stamps calm stamps.com brings all the
services of the u.s. post office
directly to your desktop buy and prints
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer and then the mail
carrier picks it up no trips to the post
office required could not be easier
stamps com not only saves you time it
saves you money because you're printing
the right amounts of postage every time
you're never over paying and with stamps
calm you get discounts on postage too
they can't even get at the post office
stamps calm is a fantastic kept this
holiday season go-to stamps calm right
now because we use it here at daily wire
offices I use it at my house as well and
right now you can enjoy the stamps calm
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
ends a digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps come click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in promo code Shapiro that
stamps calm promo code Shapiro go check
it out right now stamps calm promo code
Shapiro so as I say president Trump now
has a big win on the way here because
the left has pushed too hard on the
border issue they keep saying that open
borders are fine that a guy should not
be able to protect themselves they keep
yelling at President Trump about why the
border basically needs to be left
unprotected why the wall is a stupid
idea and Trump has been warning for a
long time that these folks were gonna
try and break through all he required
was a little bit of video of people
breaking through to justify his
questions and then it turns out people
did exactly that the attempt to downplay
this by the media is simply an attempt
to back a narrative that they had been
laying out that was subjective not
objective it's once again an indictment
of the politicization of
the media and their people who have been
trying to cover this objectively saying
okay well there are people coming to the
border that's not great if they try to
break through the border they should be
treated as criminals because they are
criminals at that point also sending
fifteen thousand troops to the border
not necessary a lot of those folks are
there superfluously for political
purposes but illegal immigration as a
problem may that be the most objective
way to cover this the media however was
fully invested in the idea and the
migrant caravan not only was a big
nothing
but that it was created just for
purposes of the election itself and once
the election was over from forgot about
it except now it's back in the headlines
why because it turns out it was an issue
after all it was an issue after all okay
now speaking of saying the unsayable as
president Trump has been doing on
immigration we got to talk about Twitter
and social media because what Twitter
and social media have been doing over
the last week and a half
really really astonishing so over the
weekend there's a guy named Jesse Kelly
Jesse Kelly is a former Marine he's a
conservative writer and radio host who's
banned from Twitter on Sunday he has
given he's been given no excuse by
Twitter why he was banned according to
the explanation and screenshot provided
by Kelly to the Daily wire this is a
piece by Amanda
presto Giacomo Twitter violated its own
policy by not informing him of the
content that apparently earned him the
permanent suspension Kelly claims the
only communication he had with Twitter
regarding the ban was the following
message your account was permanently
suspended due to multiple or repeat
violations of the Twitter rules the
account will not be restored please do
not respond to this email as replies and
new Appeals for this account will not be
monitored so they basically just killed
his his Twitter account ultimately they
just destroyed it and the fact that
Jesse Kelly was was banned from tour he
been talking about this in advance for a
long time that Twitter was cracking down
on conservatives basically Jesse Kelly
is banned for no reason louis farrakhan
still gets to call the Jews termites so
all of this is going really well over
Twitter it gets even worse over a
Twitter basically I have about 1.8
million followers on Twitter somewhere
in that neighborhood I expect to be
banned any day from Twitter why because
I maintain that a man is a man and a
woman is a woman
twitter has now adopted a policy I am
not kidding you this is a massive social
media network with a certain amount of
immunity to lawsuit okay because they
are treated as a they're they're treated
as a
common carrier basically even though
they are in fact an editorial website as
I've talked about before they're being
treated like a phone line as though they
they have no editorial discretion
they're using editorial discretion now
in vast ways and because of that it
seems to me that they should be relieved
of their of their presumption of non
guilt when it comes to violations of
copyright law for example as I've said
before legally speaking The Daily wire
rewrite we here at the Daily wire if we
run a a libel a libelous story we are
liable for that we are we are legally
liable for that you can sue us for that
that's because we are an editorial
website and we make editorial judgments
and you can sue us if we run something
libelous okay if something libelous
appears on Twitter
twitter is not sued for that why because
it's like a phone line right they're not
discriminating based on content except
they are discriminating based on content
listen to the insanity of the story
Twitter is now outright banning science
they are banning science outright for
political purposes this is according to
pink news a website from the UK Twitter
has now prohibited misgendering and dead
naming on its platform in an effort to
curtail anti-trans abuse the social
media company has changed its rules to
ban the practices and has warned that
any user who deliberately targets a
trans person in these ways may face
permanent suspension these offensive
techniques which involve using the wrong
gender to refer to a trans person or a
trans persons old name are often used on
Twitter to insult and erase trans
people's identities and right to exist
this is such propagandistic nonsense the
only way to erase somebody's right to
exist is to kill them right or to jail
them and nobody's talking about doing
any of this with transgender people but
if the idea is that I now have to say
that Caitlyn Jenner is a woman I'm not
doing that and if the idea is that
Bradley Manning right change changed his
name legally to Chelsea Manning my rule
about names by the way is that I am more
than happy to use the names which you
legally change your name because people
can change their names without changing
the underlying sex but I'm not going to
grant you in public in public discourse
about the nature of sex I'm not going to
suggest that you are a member of the
biological sex to which you do not
belong it's illogical and it's foolish
and it destroys boundaries that nature
created and that you cannot put asunder
simply because you want to but Twitter
now says that if I refer to Chelsea
Manning as a man that they could
ban me if I say Caitlyn Jenner is a man
they could ban me and if Jesse Kelly
says Caitlyn Jenner won a medal as Bruce
Jenner or that Chelsea Manning was
convicted as Bradley Manning then Jesse
Kelly could be banned permanently from
Twitter this is what dead naming is dead
naming is the idea that you are
insulting someone by using the name that
they were born with and they experienced
most of their life with and so if you
use their old name so I guess if we use
Cassius Clay's that also dead naming
things that was Muhammad Ali's name
until he changed it in the middle of his
boxing career and Twitter's updated
Terms of Service the company now states
quote we prohibit targeting individuals
with repeated slurs strokes or other
content that intends to dehumanize
degrade or reinforce negative or harmful
stereotypes about a protected category
weird because I remember when Louis
Farrakhan is still on Twitter and he
called the Jews termites house weird I
remember when I received 7400
anti-semitic slurs in the course of six
months in 2016 and the vast majority of
those people were never banned they say
that this includes misgendering or dead
naming of transgender individuals this
is absurd in the extreme absurd in the
extreme it's anti-scientific in a very
real way men are men women are women and
if you're going to argue to me that
biological sex no longer exists you're
gonna go the same way you're gonna have
the same problem the Catholic Church had
in the in the 15th century when they
were trying to claim that the universe
was geocentric hey you can't argue with
science science is still science we're
gonna get to more of social media
crackdowns in just a second and where
all of this is going because it really
is dangerous and negative but first
let's talk about how you can feed your
dog better dog food companies claim to
use natural ingredients but what kind of
beef or carrots can actually sit in a
paper bag for a year we can't see
processed foods for every meal and be
our healthiest neither can your dog this
is why you need the farmers dog the
company helping dogs live long healthy
lives with nutritious fresh ready to
serve dog meals delivered directly to
your door so I'm not a dog owner but my
sister is a dog owner and she uses the
farmers dog folks in the office have
dogs Jasper loves the farmers dog you
can even just ask chief executive dog of
The Daily wire Jasper he voraciously
gives his paw prints of Approval start
feeding your dog better today try a week
free at the farmers dog.com slash men go
check it out right now you got
shipping get your first week free at the
farmers dog calm slash Ben it is
fantastic dog owners have been
conditioned to feed their dogs basically
you know that the highly processed stuff
but instead you should be getting real
fresh food for your dog the same way
that you should be feeding yourself a
real fresh food the farmer's dog makes
it happen
studies show adding fresh food to your
dog's diet can reduce some cancers by
close to 90 percent and again start
feeding right there
with your first week free at the farmers
dog calm slash Ben that's the farmers
dog.com slash man you love your dog so
give your dog food that it wants the
farmers dog calm slash up Ben
okay so Twitter it has decided that they
are now going to ban basic science basic
science and this has led me to basically
say over and over on Twitter yesterday
and today men are men women are women
come at me bro I have Twitter wants to
if Twitter wants to ban me for saying
that men are men and women are women and
a biological sex is a thing and that the
term gender is a made-up term by social
justice warriors that has no actual
social science data to back it right if
if by gender you mean so all of
transgenderism all of the transgender
civil rights movement is based on
deliberate misclassifications of various
terms okay so if we're talking bout
biological sex there's no question that
human beings are sexually dimorphic
they're men and there are women and when
people say well there are a bunch of
sexes in between no you're now talking
about intersex disorders okay those are
actual disorders but that's like saying
that because a pencil that came off the
assembly line was mistakenly created
without an racer that pencils generally
do not have erasers or if a pencil came
off the line didn't have led that
pencils don't have lead the definition
of a pencil is that it doesn't have lead
there's no such thing as a pencil rather
that's ridiculous it's ridiculous words
have meanings terms have meanings
biological sex has a meaning and to
pretend otherwise is to deny science
it's so funny to hear all these people
love to talk about climate change
pretend there's no such thing as a man
and no such thing as a woman and so
there's biological sex then there is a
term called gender and this is where the
left has decided that gender is
basically along the spectrum of maleness
and femaleness right that have written
it there there's a bunch of genders an
infinite variety of genders in fact the
amount that your male or the allottee or
female and carry certain characteristics
and we are all different these ways
right because there are some men who are
more manly men and they love man crates
right and then there are some men
more girly men right and they love all
the sponsors over at pod save America
right there are lots of different kinds
of men right male boom more masculine
more feminine but the term gender has no
specified number of genders that exist
right it's basically just every
individual has their own gender which
means that it's a meaningless term if
you just want to say every individual on
planet earth is a mix of characteristics
sure agree but if you're a claim is that
now we have to make up a pronoun for
every one of you the pronoun is called
your name we don't actually have to do
that I'm not going to make up a pronoun
G jyggalag foo
I'm not gonna do any of that now I'm
gonna use biological terms because
biological terms are the terms that we
have historically used when we are
talking about humans and using intersex
to replace transgender is a complete
misnomer it's not the same thing at all
transgender folks are claiming they can
be fully genetically male and also
female at the same time fail fail this
is biologically not true okay so with
all of that said then folks who are on
the transgender or civil rights side
they say well okay fine you want to say
that you don't want to use our our
preferred pronouns and by the way when
it comes to individual conversation I've
been asked this repeatedly if I were out
to dinner with a transgender person well
I did a breakfast recently with a
transgender person so I go out of my way
to say pronouns that offend the person
no just like I wouldn't go out of my way
to offend you if we were at dinner even
if I thought what you were saying was
wrong right I just there's no purpose to
it but when I'm talking public policy
and how many sexes there are I'm not
going to pretend there are 93 sexes
there are not 93 sexes and pretending
this stuff does have real-world
consequences in my community in my
Jewish community there's a gym nearby
it's a gym that is sex segregated why
because Orthodox Jewish women are
supposed to be it's supposed to hue by
certain religious standards of modesty
so Orthodox Jewish women go to this gym
so it's a gym that is just for women
well last week apparently there was a
man who walked into that gym and said
I'm a transgender woman and then not
only did he walk into the gym and
claimed that he was a transgender woman
he then proceeded to disrobe in front of
all the women they have individual
lockers locker rooms like like small
private spaces where he could change but
instead this person decided that he was
a woman he had every right to change in
public
these religious women every one of those
religious women is going to now drop
their gym membership and the gym can't
do anything about it because if the gym
were to say to this guy dude you're a
biological male you need to dress by
yourself in here even if you consider
yourself a woman then they would be sued
out of existence
hey this stuff does have consequences
and those concert these women's sexist
for saying they don't want to undress
themselves in front of a male or they'd
prefer to go to a female locker room
where they don't have to see a penis and
this is this is absurd stuff so there's
a bunch of linguistic confusion that is
deliberately pervade by folks on the
social justice left with regard to this
issue and it leads to some of the most
absurd results it leads to absurd
results with actual public policy
consequences take for example this
article from the New York Times I'm not
making this up this is in the newer
times over the last three days and is by
a person named Andrea long Chu who is a
biological male who's a transgender
woman meaning a biological male who has
gender dysphoria and believes that he is
in fact a woman in a male body the title
of this article I'm not kidding you my
new vagina won't make me happy and it
shouldn't have to here's what the
article says next Thursday I will get a
vagina like wear it best by how's that
gonna work like is it - it's a cyber
monday sale ok the procedure will last
around 6 hours and I will be in recovery
for at least 3 months until the day I
die my body will regard the vagina as a
wound as a result it will require
regular painful attention to maintain
this is what I want but there is no
guarantee it will make me happier in
fact I don't expect it to that shouldn't
disqualify me from getting it
first of all let's note in this first
paragraph what this person is getting is
not a vagina what this person is getting
is a wound okay it is a wound hey vagina
is not in fact wound a vagina is a
bodily organ that does not attempt to
heal up on its own because it is a
bodily organ okay I like to say that
being trans the article says is the
second worst thing that ever happened to
me the worst was being born a boy
dysphoria is notoriously difficult to
describe to those who haven't
experienced it like a flavor it's
official definition that has stressed
some transgender feel at the in
congruence between the gender they
express and the gender they've been
socially assigned does little justice to
the feeling but in my experience at
least as Floria feels like being unable
to get warm no matter how many layers
you put on it feels like hunger without
appetite it feels like getting on an
airplane to fly home only too real
mid-flight that this is it you're gonna
spend the rest of your life on an
airplane it feels like breathing it
feels like having nothing to grieve this
is terrible obviously I mean this is
this is really terrible difficult stuff
and you can have sympathy for folks like
this and still recognize that this
person is not a biological woman will
never be a biological woman and is not a
woman in fact is a man hey many
conservatives call this crazy no we call
this a mental illness hey crazy is
derogatory mental illness is something
my grandfather had runs in my family I
mean they're people I know who are
mentally ill with whom I'm very close
who have suffered from severe mental
disorders
hey that I know that we're trying now to
basically strawman the other position on
the part of the social justice left that
if you refuse to use the the pronouns of
choice that you are now contributing to
suffering but or that you wish to but
that's just not the case a popular
right-wing narrative holds the gender
dysphoria is a clinical delusion
hence feeding of that solution with
hormones and surgeries constitutes a
violation of medical ethics right and
then here's where it gets here's what
gets to the public policy it says in
this view it is not only fair to refuse
trans people the care they seek and is
also kind a therapist where the suicidal
client does not draw the bath and supply
the razor take it from my father a
pediatrician who once remarked to me he
would no sooner prescribed puberty
blockers to a generate is for a child
then he would give a distemper shot to
someone who believed she was a dog
naturally a liberal net counter
narrative exists and it has become
increasingly mainstream transgender
people are not deluded but they are
suffering
therefore medical professionals have a
duty to ease that suffering the article
goes on and then here is where we reach
the crux of the matter
says I feel - monster ibly worse since I
started on hormones one reason is that
absent the levees of the closet years of
repressed longing for the girlhood I
never have had flooded my consciousness
I'm now a marshal and of regret another
reason is that I take estrogen
effectively delayed release sadness a
little aquamarine pill that more or less
guarantees a good weep within six to
eight hours like many of my trans
friends I've watched my dysphoria
balloon since I began transition I now
feel very strongly about the length of
my index fingers enough that I will
sometimes shyly unthread my hand for my
girlfriends as we walk down the street
when she tells me I'm beautiful I resent
it I've been outside I know what
beautiful looks like don't patronize me
I was not suicidal before hormones now I
often am I won't go through with it
killing is icky I tell you this not
because I'm cruising for sympathy but to
prepare you for what I'm telling you now
I still want this all of it I want the
tears I want the pain transition doesn't
have to make me happy for me to want it
left to their own devices people will
rarely purse what makes them feel good
in the long term desire and Happiness
are into paid our independent agents and
then this person makes the case that
basically the medical establishment
should give you a surgery even if it is
bad for you this person says the medical
max is inverted that Maxim first do no
harm
assumes that health care providers
possess both the means in the authority
to decide what counts as harm let me be
clear I believe that surgeries of all
kinds can and do make an enormous
difference in the lives of trans people
but I also believe that surgeries only
prerequisite should be a simple
demonstration of want so you want a
surgery you get a surgery and then we
can force a doctor to perform the
surgery even if it's going to be bad for
you make you more suicidal make you more
likely to kill yourself and is going to
be a gaping wound in your body for the
rest of your life if this stuff has
consequences but we can't openly discuss
it on Twitter lest we be banned
we can't openly discuss and I'm gonna
get some more of this in just one second
first if all of this makes you want to
drink then perhaps you need saucy saucy
is the alcohol delivery app saucy
delivers your favorite wine Peter looker
writes your torrents may turn be
partying it up this holiday season and
in the middle of the party and you don't
want to run out to the liquor store
because number one it might be closed
and number two you actually don't to
leave the party for an hour to go get
all the liquor instead if you're in LA
the bay area of Chicago San Diego or
Sacramento your saucy order will arrive
at your door in under 30 minutes ready
to drink for the rest of us saw she
delivers beer wine and liquor to your
door in two days or less nationwide no
order minimums no delivery fees no
running to the store if you got the
saucy app you got a fully stocked bar
right there on your phone and for a
limited time and get $15 off when you
download the saucy app and enter promo
code Ben that's the saucy app spelled
sauc ey and her promo code Ben for $15
off get the saucy app today use promo
code Ben again you're gonna be needing
drinks this holiday season if only to
get through it with your relatives this
is why you ought to be checking out the
saucy app sauc ey I'm gonna use promo
code Ben you get $15 off even if you're
just an occasional drinker even if you
just want to make sure that your
relatives don't have to don't have to be
quite so edgy all the time well then
saucy is for you because let's be real
about this everyone could use a little
alcohol this time in the air when you're
with your family this much check it out
ese
you see ey enter promo code Ben for $15
off that is saucy and get that saucy app
today and use that promo code Ben
already so more on social medias crack
down on science and discussions that we
have to have in public and that must be
had but first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wired.com for $9.99 a
month you can subscribe one of the
reasons you should subscribe by the way
is to ensure that when all these social
media sites crack down on conservatives
you can still get all of our content go
check us out right now over at daily
wired.com for $9.99 a month get the rest
of this show live the recipe under
Clavin the show live the rest of Michael
Knowles is execrable show live
don't miss Andrew clavin's next chapter
of another kingdom performed by Michael
moles today subscribers get exclusive
access to episode eight titled the
darkest hour aka the Democrats take over
the house if you're not a subscriber you
won't be able to watch new episodes of
season two until Friday so what are you
waiting for you could be getting it
early and you could be watching all the
great art head on over to Daley wire.com
subscribe to watch the first and second
seasons of another Kingdom also we have
lots more goodies that are coming up in
the new year once you become a
subscriber you get two additional hours
of this show are you kidding me I'm not
I'm gonna be here doing it every day
okay you're even going to be there you
get all that stuff when you subscribe
like right now so you should totally go
over and do that right now for $99 a
year you get all of those aforementioned
wonders Plus this the very greatest in
beverage vessels look upon it and sigh
and they're like I wish if only if only
I'd let my wife drink from the left
Astaire's hot or cold tumbler over the
weekend should have been able to avoid
the grave disease that now flicks her
but if you want to avoid all disease if
you want to be healthy for the rest of
your life if you never want to die then
you ought to go out and get the leftist
here's hot real cold tumble none of
that's guaranteed by the way you know no
that's here anything I'm just its theory
it's been said not fda-approved it's
been set so go check it out right now
you got all those things for $99 a year
with is cheaper than the monthly
subscription go check it out right now
we have the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so Twitter is cracking down on all
expressions of science with regard to
sex twitter is refusing to allow any
sort of conversations about the nature
of gender dysphoria when gender surgery
sex reassignment sex cannot be
reassigned by the way because it was
never assigned in the first place to be
reassigned sex would have to be assigned
it was not assigned you were born with
it ok any more than I was assigned to my
foot and cutting off my foot would be
reassigning my foot that's not how this
works just because he changed the body
part that we're talking about here does
not mean you had your sex reassigned and
so that this this whole thing is is
really absurd the language of it is
absurd but Twitter is now going to
enforce it
hey this basic censorship is unamerican
it's unamerican
twitter is acting in unamerican fashion
by shutting down necessary public policy
conversations on the basis that is
offensive to someone
hey this is feelings over fact and let's
be real about this if Twitter believes
that it is now the job of Twitter to
prevent social conversations on
important public topics because some
people may take it the wrong way then
Twitter is gonna be banning everybody
except for jackal apparently has all the
right views Jack Dorsey the head of
Twitter it's not just Twitter by the way
there's a report that got very very
little attention when it was reported in
the Wall Street Journal a little bit
earlier this year it's amazing that's
didn't get more attention the Wall
Street Journal reported two weeks ago
that Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg
pressured a top executive at his company
to apologize for his support of
President Trump in the 2016 election and
then issue a letter just before the
election explaining that he had switched
his support to libertarian Gary Johnson
according to reporters
Kirsten grind and Keach Hagee oculus
founder Palmer Luckey says she was put
on leave and then fired for his support
for Trump The Journal reported quote in
the fall of 2016 as unhappiness over the
dinner nation simmered Facebook
executives including mr. Zuckerberg
pressured mr. lucky to publicly voiced
support for libertarian candidate Gary
Johnson despite mr. Lucky's years-long
support of mr. Trump according to people
familiar with the conversations and
internal emails viewed by The Wall
Street Journal lucky ended up
negotiating a hundred million dollar
settlement an acceleration of stock
awards and bonuses he would have
received thanks to his sale of oculus VR
to Facebook in 2014 Facebook denied he
was fired for his political views but
lucky was a supporter of President Trump
for years
going back to 2011 when he urged Trump
to run for president by mail in
September 2016 The Daily Beast reported
lucky had given a $10,000 donation to
nimble America which was an anti Hillary
ad group focused on trolling her lucky
then apparently posted on a reddit chain
under a pseudonym regarding Clinton he
posted Hillary Clinton is corrupt a war
monger a freedom stripper not the good
kind you see dancing in bikinis on
Independence Day the bad kind that
strips freedom from citizens and grants
its donors Facebook employees complained
about lucky with engineering director
Raveena's Narayan Arianna and writing
quote multiple women have literally
teared up in front of me in the last few
days some developers said they wouldn't
work with lucky lucky tonight he posted
about Clinton under pseudonym he added
he was a libertarian who voted for Gary
Johnson here is what the Journal report
said I need to tell you that Zuckerberg
himself drafted this and details are
critical said Facebook deputy general
counsel Paul garwal he wrote to where
four voted two for lucky and a September
2016 email attaching an early draft of
the statement the draft said lucky would
not be supporting Trump in the election
lucky told people he did vote for mr.
Johnson not only to avoid having his
credibility questioned if he was asked
about the issue under oath in unrelated
litigation the apology went through many
drafts lucky ultimately approved changes
suggested by Facebook according to
people familiar with the process amazing
stuff so Facebook basically took out a
guy for a hundred million dollars after
trying to force him to say that he
didn't vote for Trump and voted instead
for Gary Johnson these social media
companies do not appreciate basic
political views from anywhere to the
right of censor anywhere anywhere and
it's it's gradually moving from the
fringes so they're a bunch of
conservatives you see now pseudo
conservatives and conservatives on
Twitter and on Facebook you know like
well if they ban this guy they ban Alex
Jones or Laura Loomer or people who we
find unpalatable
well the alligator will eat us last
right yellow Gator will eat you blast
and then we'll eat you I despise Alex
Jones I think that Laura Loomer is a
crackpot that doesn't matter the fact is
that once you start banning people for a
political viewpoint that is nonviolent
in orientation and it's non slanderous
and non legally actionable you end up in
a place where the only approved opinions
are the approved opinions of Mark
Zuckerberg or Jack Dorsey that's what's
happening here and you can see it
manifest it's so funny how strange a new
respect from the left only lasts as long
as your
useful tool for the left so over a
crooked media there's another story over
a crooked media's her crooked media of
course lead the folks behind pod save
America and you know these seem like
nice dudes I haven't really had a lot of
dealings with them is Jon Favreau Jon
love it and Tommy Vietor they announced
that they dumped a guy named Tim Miller
Tim Miller is a number Trump Republican
he'd been hired by crooked media as
their token Republican but then they
fired him why did they fire him because
it turns out that Tim Miller had been
working with a group called definers
public affairs and that group had been
working with Facebook to reveal the fact
that George Soros was pushing a lot of
propaganda against Facebook so crooked
media fired Tim Miller
so Miller was good when he was
criticizing Trump he was good when he
kept criticizing Trump continuously but
when he did things that they didn't like
then they fired him so they put out a
statement said we wanted to give you an
update on Tim Miller we invited Tim to
contribute to crooked because he took a
public stand against Trump when most of
his party capitulated that took courage
and unlike many Republicans who declared
themselves to be never Trump errs during
the campaign he's still won today in
other words him yelling at Trump all the
time that's why we hired him tim is an
insightful voice about what is broken in
the Republican Party his repeatedly
denounced racism and bigotry from Trump
and other Republican politicians but
when we read the New York Times story
about Facebook's campaign to discredit
its critics we were surprised and angry
about the role that definers Public
Affairs the firm Tim sometimes partners
with played in that effort so Tim Miller
gone but the strange new respect the
Left feels for some people on the right
last only so long as they believe that
those people are our tools of the left
the minute that those people suddenly
become not tools of the left then they
have to be dumped on the side of the
road as soon as possible okay in other
news things getting very very dangerous
over in Ukraine according to the Kiev
Post at an emergency meeting late on the
night of November 25th the military
cabinet passed a resolution to impose
martial law in Ukraine in the wake of an
attack on and seizure of Ukrainian Navy
boats by the Russian Coast Guard in the
neutral waters of the Azov sea on
November 25th President Petro poroshenko
said he would appeal to the Ukrainian
Parliament on November 26th to approve
his declaration of martial law which
could lead to widespread compulsory
military service
restrictions on media and public
demonstrations and suspension of
elections among other measures
what exactly happened well the Ukrainian
Navy reported that the Russian Coast
Guard boats opened fire on three
Ukrainian boats in the Azov sea on the
evening of
of November 25th after Russian officials
announced they had trespassed its
territorial waters the Kerch Strait the
Strait connecting the Black Sea in the
as I see has been closed off for on non
mil non-military vessels in a shootout
Ukraine's small armored artillery boats
sustained damage and Rameau belies the
Ukrainians hug boat had been rammed by a
Russian Coast Guard ship Don earlier in
the morning all three vessels were
seized by a Russian special ops unit
this is essentially an act of war and it
looks like things could get violence it
could get violent very quickly here yeah
Ukraine has demanded that Russia release
sailors and ships as the tensions are
getting worse there's been a call for a
UN Security Council resolution which
isn't going to happen obviously because
Russia actually sits on the UN Security
Council so all of this is is getting
very dire and the possibility of a new
war between Ukraine and Russia is
certainly on the horizon here it's one
of the reasons why it's been a mistake
for the President of the United States
to poo-pooed NATO and suggest that NATO
is no longer necessary all that does is
give all sorts of credence to the
Russian aggression in the region I said
this one Obama was president I'll say it
again one Trump is president the Russian
policy has basically been push until you
hit steel or there's been true since
Stalin that you just keep pushing until
you finally hit the wall and right now
they found no wall and Russia has been
piecemealing
parts of Eastern Europe they've grabbed
they've grabbed obviously Crimea they
invaded Georgia during the Bush
administration and there's been no
strong response from the American
administration whether it was bush or
Obama and now it's up to President Trump
to issue a stronger response saying NATO
will defend Ukrainian territory if
Ukrainian territory is in fact attacked
now do we want to be in a shooting war
no but that's the whole reason of having
deterrence the whole reason of having
currents is that if you keep backing off
your points if you keep backing off the
line the Russians will keep pushing to
the point where you actually do reach a
line that cannot be crossed it's all fun
and games appeasement until it turns out
that you can no longer appease you
actually have to fight back so for all
the folks who are more isolationist in
the Republican Party understand if you
don't want to go to war you have to you
have to stand up on your hind legs and
threaten to go to war sometimes yeah you
actually do
I can't just be that you are there only
to defend your vital interest because
that means that your vital interest will
be attacked sooner rather than later
everyone's going to assume that you
won't even defend those especially if
you can't even define what those vital
interests are in the first place okay
time for some things that I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like over the weekend I read a
good new novel by a guy named Seth
Greenland he's a TV writer he's
definitely on the political left the the
book is called the hazards of good
fortune and it's sort of like a a weaker
version of Tom Wolf's bonfire of the
vanities
Masek plot is that there's this Jewish
basketball team owner who is who's
secular Jew his his daughter has
obviously become extraordinarily
politically radical as you would expect
and gender fluid as you would also
expect and all the rest of it and he is
also struggling with racial politics on
his team and struggling with his wife
the book itself is a really good for
Goethe he's one of the funniest things
is that when the left critiques the
shortcomings of the left
it sounds very right-wing this book was
certainly not meant to be right-wing it
is in fact however a very right-wing
book because this book basically is
about these shortcomings of a secular
Jewish lifestyle that has no connection
to heritage history or religion and how
that ends with people trying to appease
groups they can't appease how it ends
with people trying to fulfill social
justice warrior standards that they can
never fulfill and how if you have no
standards for your own kids then your
kids end up having different standards
for you to which you will always fall
short the book is worth reading the
hazards of good fortune it's a very
quick read it's juicy and pulpy Larry
David recommends it because it is funny
it does have a couple of scenes that are
that are pretty funny as we check it out
Seth Green's lens the hazards of good
fortune okay time for some things that I
hate
so Alexander Ocasio Cortez continues to
make headlines again the only reason we
cover her is because the left has
declared her a very important human and
this means that we must cover her
because we cover that which is very
important she tweeted out over the
weekend insurance groups are
recommending GoFundMe as official policy
or customers can die if they can't raise
the goal in time but sure single-payer
health care is unreasonable and then she
tweeted out a photo of a letter received
by a person who'd been denied certain
health care coverage and urged to start
to GoFundMe this led a doctor named
Nikki Johnson to tweet out this tweet
actually is representative of the
ignorance of many legislators not just
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez the vast
majority of them do not understand
health care or health insurance and
definitely not the practice of medicine
if they make laws about it and some want
government to run it and she talked
specifically in this particular case
about how this letter is not coming in
fact from an Insurance Group this is
actually coming from a Medicaid group
this is actually coming from a sponsored
government group that basically had a
board that denied people a the
immunosuppressive medications for a
heart transplant for example so this is
not in fact coming from a private
insurance company and yet it was being
treated that way
by Alexandra Ocasio Cortes because
obviously everything that's bad is the
private market and everything that's
good is the public market even though
denials of coverage in single payer
states in nationalized health care
states are extraordinarily regular your
waiting in line for coverage at 4-4
surgeries for years and years and years
and at the more expensive end of the
scale you simply don't get drug
sometimes it's not like they have an
unlimited amount of money to spend they
simply don't which is why the five-year
cancer survival rates in the United
States are the highest of any
industrialized country it is also why if
you remove homicide and car crash deaths
from the American death rolls than what
you see is that America's life
expectancy is actually higher than any
other industrialized country which is a
much better reflection of our health
care status the idea that America is a
great outlier when it comes to health
care and we suck all this much and we
got serious problems in the American
healthcare system but you actually have
to understand that health care system
before you can before you can hone in on
what those problems are okay other
things that I hate today
so John Kasich oh god no please God no
not John Kasich Governor of Ohio he says
that maybe he wants to run now John
Kasich in preparation for his run just
vetoed
the fetal heartbeat bill that would
protect the lives of babies in the womb
once they have a heartbeat which is
presumably around nine ten weeks when
it's detectable anyway here is John
Kasich saying maybe he'll run for
president because who wants him to run
well John Kasich wants him to run who
will vote for John Kasich well John
Kasich will vote for John Kasich but
here's why this is all explained why
this is such a dumb idea in just a
second how seriously are you thinking
about taking it on this time very
seriously I'm considering a Georgia
these are earnest conversations that go
on virtually every day with some of my
friends with my family look I we need
different leadership there's an any
question about it and I'm not only just
worried about the tone and the
name-calling and the division in our
country and the partisanship but I also
worry about the policies a man who
strongly resembles a piece of wad of
paper that you dropped in your pocket
and then went through the washing
machine and now says that he is worried
about the tone in our politics I mean
John Kasich by the way has said some
pretty nasty things to a wide variety of
people he says he said that failing to
expand government in the state of Ohio
was the anti-biblical a pretty amazing
statement and of course vetoed the fetal
heartbeat built the other day here is
why this is a dumb idea it would be a
dumb idea even if it were coming from
somebody actually liked it not John
Kasich I think John Kasich says schmuck
so put that aside even if it were coming
from somebody that I actually like let's
say that you're Mike Lee or Ben Sasse or
Ted Cruz or somebody who I think would
be a great president who was who was
running against Trump here's why this is
a bad idea
Trump has a high level of support inside
the Republican Party anyone who runs
against Trump will immediately be other
if a quote-unquote true con were to run
against Trump all that would do would it
be to alienate everyone who supports
Trump from those true con positions
because as we know Trump is not an
ideologue he is happy to attack
conservative positions if he thinks it
will get him ahead in the polls and a
lot of his followers are willing to
temporarily put aside those conservative
positions because Trump is actually a
pretty good tool for policy on a bunch
of various areas running against Trump
would lead to the false perception
inside the Republican Party that
conservatism is dead when in fact it's
just that a lot of people are personally
loyal to the President of the United
States and believe that he is doing some
good things and will back him over a
more conservative candidate
the fact that a more conservative
candidate will get you know 10% of the
vote will then be used by the media to
proclaim that conservatism is dead
populism is on the rise
I would prefer the reality to continue
to be the reality which is that there
are a lot of conservatives to support
from a lot of non conservatives who
support Trump Trump is the president
he'll run for reelection he'll get the
nomination I see no purpose in
ceaselessly and Li needlessly polarizing
the party around a fake fake gap between
populist and conservative simply to
assuage the ego of somebody like John
Kasich okay final thing that I hate
today
so people on the Left am making a very
big deal over a new government report
that delivers a dire warning about
climate change and it's devastating
impacts saying the economy could lose
hundreds of billions of dollars or in
worst case scenario more than ten
percent of its GDP by the end of the
century we've discussed this at length
before there a couple of Nobel Prize
winners in economics this year who
talked about when in fact it would be
worthwhile for us to start investing in
various forms of attempting to curb
climate change particularly carbon
credits and their estimate was it would
only start being profit neutral once the
climate was expected to warm more than
three point five degrees Celsius that is
a very large change in terms of the
engine in terms of temperature the the
kind of overweening despair that you are
seeing by folks on the Left climate
change is happening we're all going to
die not only are L going to die it's
going to destroy the economy you know
what else would destroy the economy look
right now you wonder store more than 10%
of GDP like right now Institute a
massive carbon credits regime and prove
and regulate all of the industries that
actually drive America's energy industry
by the way the idea that carbon
emissions are chiefly coming from the
United States is a lie last year the
United States was the number one country
on planet earth and reducing carbon
emissions other countries that are
developing like China and India are
mostly responsible for the increase in
carbon emissions there are signatories
to the Paris Accords but the Paris
Accords are done because the Paris
Accords basically say that China has no
obligation to cut emissions until like
2030 which means that they're gonna
continue emitting at extraordinarily
rapid rates even as the US has
additional technology and wealth allow
us to take environmentalism more
seriously that's not stopping the left
though from saying that climate change
is going to kill everyone we're all
going to die and we'll pretend there are
no downsides to any of this stuff even
as there are riots in
Harris hey the riots happening in Paris
Franck Bueller is according to the Alice
France Presse Frank Bueller is a leader
of the protesters for barricaded French
highways over the past week he aims to
color parents in the movements trademark
yellow on Saturday when rural France
takes its fight with President Emmanuel
macron to the capital what exactly are
they fighting he's a member of the
right-wing stand up france party Bueller
has watched in horror as fuel prices
soared in the past years driving up the
cost of his commute to work in the rural
southwestern tarnat coronal region said
I spent between 1 and 2 months wages on
fuel he says that this is because of the
anti pollution taxes is because of
carbon credits so there are in fact a
bunch of serious consequences to taking
this sort of action folks on the Left
are urging a 23% rise in the price of
diesel in the past year is what has
happened in France the government has
linked the price search to world oil
prices but the yellow vests accuse
McCrone of punishing motorists while
slashing taxes on business and the
wealthy basically there's a massive gas
tax in France and a lot of it has to do
with attempts to fulfill the pledges of
the climate Accords if we actually want
to have an intelligent conversation
about climate change we have to
recognize carbon taxes actually have
downsides and we also have to recognize
that carbon taxes on industrialized
countries like France in the United
States are not going to stop carbon
emissions from China and India and then
perhaps you have to figure out how
exactly we spur innovation without
attempting to destroy jobs and destroy
lives all over the world but this is a
conversation people don't want to have
they want it to boil down to you either
don't take climate change seriously if
you don't want to massively destroy the
world economy and tax people to death or
you take climate change or or you deny
science you're not Ellison I'm not
denying climate change is happening I'm
not even denying that man is a main
cause of that climate change I am
questioning whether the extent of the
climate change necessitates the kind of
precipitous action folks on the Left
want to take I'm asking at what point we
should start taking more severe action
how that action actually correlates with
an attempt to reduce the the climate and
is it possible that free market
solutions still provide a better option
since again natural gas replacing coal
has been mainly the driver of emissions
coming down in the United States over
the past several years ok well we will
be back here tomorrow with all the
latest I'm sure there will be plenty
mortises we're back in the news cycle
hope you had a wonderful Thanksgiving
Day weekend
I'm in the home checking my wife make
sure she's doing okay I'll catch you
later I mentioned Bo this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018